qu'est-ce que tu peux nous dire ce soir
je peux vous dire que on va s'écrire ces
influenceurs et merci d'avoir dénoncé
leur arnaque et le combat continue je ne
peux pas tolérer un harcèlement en meute
d'accord
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Pogba dans la foulée de médias l'AFP
France Info nous donne des précisions
Jean-Paul conditionnel il y aurait une
enquête ouverte depuis début août pour
tentative ou carrément extorsion
d'argent sur Paul Pogba Paul Pogba au
policiers aurait déclaré que début
juillet à Turin où il revenait à la
Juventus à l'entraînement il aurait été
victime d'une intimidation par deux
hommes cagoulés et armés de fusils
d'assaut visant à lui extorquer 13
millions d'euros
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce qu'on a parlé
d'affaires de sorcellerie c'est quoi
cette affaire sur alors j'ai entendu ça
aussi c'est quoi c'est j'ai lu ça ça
c'est le volet Mbappe de l'affaire on
apprend hier que ce que s'apprêtait ou
s'apprêterait à révéler Mathias c'est un
maraboutage de Kylian Mbappé commandité
par Paul Pogba via un marabout pour lui
jeter un sort
[Musique]
plus que la guerre en Ukraine c'est la
guerre entre Booba et Magali Bernard et
c'est vrai c'est ça qui est dramatique
c'est un truc de fou tout le monde ne
parlait que de ça
tu vas pas vous lâcher sur les réseaux
sociaux il dénonce presque chaque jour
les pratiques commerciales douteuses de
ces célébrités d'Internet qui l'accusent
d'escroquerie comme ceci et c'est trop
bien ça fait des trop joli boucles
que ce sont des produits voilà qui
peuvent être nocifs pour la santé
regardez on a même été voir une personne
qui se dit être victime de ses produits
vendus par les influenceurs je m'appelle
Abla je chef d'entreprise et j'estime
que j'ai été victime d'une injustice
même voir d'une arnaque chez un coiffeur
les conséquences du lissage dès le
premier shampoing c'est-à-dire trois
jours après mais je fais sont tombés en
masse donc j'ai eu très peur sur le
moment je me suis dit c'est les effets
du lissage ça va passer je commençais à
ne plus avoir de cheveux du tout j'ai
perdu plus de la moitié de mes cheveux
alors la question qu'on se pose Patrick
Bruel c'est les influenceurs sont-ils
des escrocs qui sont les influenceurs ce
sont des gens qui ont une inf où ça sur
les réseaux sociaux et réseaux sociaux
on sait que c'est le seul ou principal
vecteur de culture d'intérêt notamment
de la jeunesse la société shonaibens
elle a été mise en cause en l'occurrence
puisque la société
qui dirigeait pas Magali Berda et Magali
Berba se présente comme le principal
agent d'influenceuse par exemple
elle-même elle a fait de la vente de de
formation
pouvant être financés par le compte de
professionnels de formation donc tant
elle-même que ces influenceurs ont été
mis en cause pourquoi parce que derrière
des produits qu'elle a fait qu'elle a
vendu dont elle a fait la promotion il y
avait de l'abus donc il y a eu les
phénomènes quand même c'est extrêmement
grave la chirurgie esthétique on a vendu
à des gamines des prestations de
chirurgie esthétique ça a été n'importe
quoi là on parle quand même de santé
publique donc entre la santé publique
d'un côté et des gens qui se sont
truffés qui n'osent pas porter plainte
parce que dénoncer un influenceur c'est
prendre le risque de se voir flasher sur
un réseau social par quelqu'un qui une
fois comme vous peut-être des centaines
de milliers de followers donc les gens
ont peur personne ne dit rien donc là
moi je dis heureusement que c'est
trouver Booba qui franchement n'est pas
très modéré par la peur qui a vu ce truc
qu'il l'a pris en main qui l'a pris en
grippe on aura
décidé de le dénoncer ça va mon Booba
regarde
fais gaffe quand même comment ça va
ça va
je t'entends mal je t'entends on
t'entend hyper mal qu'est-ce que tu peux
nous dire ce soir
je peux vous dire que on va se faire ces
influenceurs et merci d'avoir dénoncé
leur Tornade et le combat continue
vers cette vidéo qui a fait scandale et
qui tournait énormément sur les réseaux
sociaux de pire soir on y voit le
rappeur timal vous connaissez timal
non moi je sais qu'il a fait un feat
avec Booba et un autre Jul c'est tout ce
que je sais
pas
si mal regardé ce qu'il a fait parce que
il fait énormément parler de lui et ce
snap regarde
voilà alors c'est vrai que ça c'est en
fait non non
les réseaux sociaux bien sûr appelons
boycott du rappeur la Fondation 30
Millions d'Amis à mais non annoncé sur
Twitter avoir effectué un signalement à
la plateforme pharose porter plainte
pour maltraitance animale et demander la
mise en sécurité de l'animal qu'est-ce
qui se passe alors non mais il y a rien
à dire à part que c'est un demeurer moi
cette vidéo elle me brise le cœur
j'avais même pas à l'avoir à quel moment
même si tu as bu même si ta fumé j'en
sais rien si tu es pas dans ton état
normal à quel moment tu te dis que tu
vas frapper ton chien violemment au
crâne comme ça que tu vas filmer et tu
vas poster la vidéo et encore plus
facteur aggravant quand tu es censé être
un modèle pour les jeunes c'est très
grave j'espère qu'il aura de vrais
sanctions et pas des travaux d'intérêt
général pour moi ça mérite la prison ça
c'est horrible alors
prisonnement et 45000 euros d'amende
pas parce qu'il m'ait fait une deuxième
vidéo où il dit en fait il montre le
chat
et de quel animal c'est pas lui taper
dessus c'est pas ça l'éducation d'un
animal désolé
il a montré les pipis mais il engueule
visiblement parce qu'il a fait pipi le
chat mais c'est de sa faute il a fait
pipi le chien un chien bien élevé il
fait pas pipi à la maison donc c'est lui
qui est en tort et cette image sont
ignobles et je crois qu'il est au poste
déjà ce soir aujourd'hui quand vous
faites ça immédiatement les réseaux
sociaux sont pas vous êtes signalés
parce qu'il a filmé oui
tout de suite c'est signalé et quelques
heures après il y a une plainte qui est
déposée par 30 millions d'amis il est en
garde à vue et il y aura des sanctions
avant il y avait pas ça donc il faut se
féliciter de la mobilisation générale il
y a eu la loi contre la maltraitance
animale et maintenant ça va très vite
voilà pour l'instant sanctionner pour
l'instant le chien lui a été retiré
en fait il y avait deux chiens donc
celui-là a été retiré et l'autre chien
aussi a été retiré et donc 31 amis à
porter plainte pour sévis grave et hack
de cruauté donc ça ça va jusqu'à 60 000
euros et en plus ils ont mis plus
diffusion relative aux actes de ces vis
donc ça ça pourrait faire filmer en plus
et en fait ce qui est très important de
dire c'est que lorsque vous voyez ça
chez un voisin c'est chez un voilà il
faut signaler les choses et 30 Millions
d'Amis ils sont vraiment ouverts il y a
un mail que vous pouvez retrouver sur
internet et pour les contacter en fait
[Musique]
si le grand frère a été beaucoup plus de
s'exprimer publiquement sous peine de
personne ou sa liberté du fait que son
petit frère le voulant mort ou en prison
laisse plutôt pas le petit frère qui
aurait trahi le grand frère le grand
frère ne m'oublie pas parce qu'il a
refait une vidéo il y a quelques heures
là pour dire voyez tout ce que
j'annonçais est avéré ce qui se passe
c'est que Paul Pogba a été entre
guillemets obligé reconnaître devant les
enquêteurs qu'il avait un marabout voilà
et il paye ce marabout pour l'empêcher
d'avoir des blessures ce qui n'a pas
marché parce que il est actuellement
blessé en revanche il y a une
confirmation qu'il y a deux mecs qui
sont arrivés au centre d'entraînement de
Turin où jouait Pogba avec un mec en
voiture on a demandé à ce que Paul Pogba
sorte il n'a pas voulu sortir et c'est
pour ça qu'il est allé porter plainte et
en Italie et en France donc ça ça a été
confirmé aussi alors vous vous dites que
Mathias a fait cette vidéo parce que en
fait il travaillait avec son frère c'est
l'histoire il était oui
il a été écarté quand il a été écarté en
mars quand il y a eu quand Paul Pogba
s'aperçoit qu'on l'arnaque il vire tout
le monde dont son frère et il se sépare
vraiment de plusieurs membres de sa
famille et là ça crée des clashs et il
se murmure qu'il y aurait peut-être j'en
peux encore conditionnel des affaires
d'argent derrière tout ça
il y a un amalgame qui a été créé sur
les réseaux sociaux
je pense volontairement aujourd'hui
depuis le mois de mai donc moi si je
suis venu ici ce soir sur ce plateau je
vais vous le dire très clairement c'est
uniquement par rapport à mes enfants par
rapport à ma famille parce que demain
c'est la rentrée des classes et que j'ai
pas envie que ma famille que mes enfants
rentrent dans la cour de récréation avec
la boule au ventre comme elles l'ont
depuis trois mois et demi
parce qu'il s'est dit des choses sur ce
plateau lundi
qui sont pour moi
impardonnable c'est inacceptable d'avoir
occulté ce qui s'est passé dans ma vie
depuis trois mois et demi on est quand
même une famille ici vous me l'avez déjà
plusieurs reprises et j'ai entendu
toutes les discours que vous avez tenus
sur le harcèlement
de s'exprimer mais l'avocat ne vous a
pas attaqué à nomine
nous ce que veulent les gens est-ce que
veulent savoir les Français c'est s'il y
a des arnaques ou pas je vais vous dire
la guéguerre Booba Magali Berda bien sûr
ça nous fait non mais non mais ça fait
de la peine à tout le monde ça fait de
la peine à tout le monde ça gêne tout le
monde ça fait de la peine à tout le
monde on est très triste pour votre
famille
si vous aviez votre enfant qui vous
demandez est-ce que c'est est-ce que
c'est soit sur une vidéo pornographique
qu'on lui envoie par milliers est-ce que
recevoir aujourd'hui
on reviendrait pour ça on a une baisse
de chiffre d'affaires qui est
conséquente aussi depuis un an et demi
deux ans parce qu'on a refusé énormément
de sites on refuse de plus en plus de
sites on a créé un service juridique on
a mis plein de choses en place et ça ça
date de il y a deux ans maintenant pour
que ce soit propre si vous voulez que le
milieu de l'influence soit propre et je
l'ai déjà dit donc c'est pour ça que
c'est pas que je ne veux pas m'en
justifier parce que je trouve que je
n'ai pas mon justifié je l'ai déjà fait
mais je vais le redire si ça vous
intéresse il faut qu'il y ait des règles
qui soient mis en place j'ai contacté
plusieurs
personnes des autorités compétentes
l'année dernière pour leur demander des
rendez-vous pour parler avec eux pour
discuter pour leur proposer des choses
parce que je suis sur le terrain depuis
2016 et que j'estime que
je j'attends j'attends les rendez-vous
et on a arrêté de parler de CPF depuis
le mois de février c'est-à-dire que nous
nos influenceurs on a pu le faire on le
fait plus dans les briefs on demande à
ce que ce soit plus un argument parce
que malheureusement il y a des gens
malhonnêtes qui passent des accords avec
des gens et tout et nous on veut pas
rentrer là-dedans je ne peux pas tolérer
un harcèlement en meute d'accord
c'est pas possible oui mais l'affaire a
commencé comme ça c'est que j'ai juste
que chronologiquement
remettre les choses à leur place et
c'est pour ça que je suis venu parce que
je veux que les gens qui vous regardent
l'entendent parce que lundi ne l'ont pas
attendre ils l'ont pas entendu Booba il
faut tirer jusqu'à la mort mais moi en
fait je suis pas là pour faire un un
combat de boxe en fait je suis là pour
vivre travailler j'ai on a des employés
qui qui se lèvent le matin qui sont
respectables et il faut les respecter
aussi
depuis que le rappeur dénonce les
pratiques commerciales des influenceurs
de camp semble désormais s'opposer il y
a d'un côté ceux qui dénonce ce système
mais les produits que ces célébrités
d'Internet nous vendent sur les réseaux
sociaux on est complètement gonflé je ne
conseille absolument pas ce produit pour
des pigeons se trouvent les influenceurs
pour qui leur pratique n'ont rien dit
légal n'écoutez pas tout ce que vous
voyez sur les réseaux sociaux la
personne qui arnaquer personne vous
inquiétez pas est-ce que c'est vrai que
il y a des produits qui valent 10 balles
qui sont vendus 50 balles par exemple
pour te dire non il y a des produits qui
se vendent 10 balles apparemment que
d'autres 250 balles maintenant nous on
n'est pas entre guillemets
on sait moi en tout cas moi je parle
pour moi je me lève pas le matin en
disant tiens je vais voler la France je
vais venir je vais prendre un truc sur
Aliexpress et je vais le vendre 50 euros
alors qu'il m'a coûté 5 euros c'est pas
mon but d'accord on a une on a des
agences
et en vrai on travaille main dans la
main donc je remets pas tout sur les
agences c'est pas vrai eux ils viennent
ils nous propose quelque chose tu veux
le faire ou tu veux tu sais même pas ce
que c'est en fait c'est pas si il faut
que je sais ce que c'est mais c'est tout
dépend les agences j'ai vu d'un côté
l'avocat de Booba qui vient poser les
choses en termes juridique et expliquer
quels sont les problèmes qui se posent
j'ai vu de l'autre une jeune femme une
influenceuse qui finalement
tout à fait et qui vient t'expliquer
qu'elle a créé un métier toute pièce
dont elle ignorait tout de celui-ci
puisque forcément il n'existait pas et
que elle a peut-être fait des erreurs
mais c'est une bonne fois ben oui mais
si ces erreurs elles consistent dans des
pratiques commerciales trompeuses ou nos
escroquerie s'appelle pas des erreurs
sur terre quand même en fait là où ça me
fait marrer votre plateau c'est que
quand moi je balance des trucs tout le
monde est contre moi bouge pas moi quand
il est venu il a dit la même chose que
moi et tout le monde
il y a 2 minutes vous parliez oui vous
voulez qu'on fasse main dans la main et
tout ça pas du tout
ensemble on sait pas copains
pour réguler les pratiques rien d'autre
excusez-moi un objectif
c'est important qu'on ne fasse ensemble
c'est ce que vous avez dit
vous vous rappelez ça c'est bon ça va ok
d'accord vous venez ici pour autant vous
tapez sur nous en disant c'est des
idiots tu es bête des toute la journée
comment vous voulez qu'on fasse un
panneau
vous avez parlé 20 minutes laisse-le
parler ok merci donc comment on fait si
nous on veut venir vers vous mais toute
la journée on sent insulter comment on
fait pour vous ouvrir les portes et se
dire quoi on va faire quelque chose
ensemble enfin dites-moi
jusqu'ici parce que vous avez envie de
venir j'étais insulté
vous moi
je veux dire ça vous intéresse pas que
je réponde vous êtes la victime
permanente hier soir hier soir méga
libertin était la victime de Booba mais
si vous êtes une victime permanente pour
l'instant les vrais victimes ce sont
celles vous en savez rien
je vais vous ramener un nez rouge
merci Christelle Camus de d'être avec
nous vous êtes productrice et de du
spectacle donc de ce que vous étiez la
productrice de Jean-Marie Bigard je suis
toujours officiellement la productrice
de Jean-Marie Bigard jusqu'en décembre
2023 est-ce qu'ils ont bien préparé un
spectacle ensemble Dieudonné Jean-Marie
Bigard alors oui le spectacle est
présenté
le spectacle part sur la route mais
parmi sans ma Jean-Marie
c'est peut-être ce qu'il dit il ne sera
pas sur la tournée pourquoi parce que
Laurent effectivement lui a proposé de
revenir aux grosses têtes et Jean-Marie
a énormément peur que en disant qu'il
est sur ce fameux duo qui ne puisse pas
faire le contrat avec avec Laurent que
j'apprécie énormément mais c'est pas ça
parce que Jean-Marie parle de pression
il utilise toujours des mots un peu trop
fort et trop important c'est pas
dépression c'est des conseils
quelques-uns de ses amis proches sur toi
tu l'as vu au téléphone moi je lui au
téléphone cet été quand il m'a annoncé
ça il n'osait même pas me l'annoncer
c'était Lola d'ailleurs qui a annoncé
elle était à côté de lui et je lui dis
mais fais pas ça j'en ai mais c'est pas
une pression il fait ce qu'il veut il
est grand c'est juste un conseil un
conseil amical je suis pas le seul et il
s'est Moon évidemment Laurent Baffie
j'imagine François Rollin quelques-uns
de ses meilleurs amis parce que moi je
fais pas partie de son entourage proche
on a été plusieurs à lui dire ça va être
la connerie de plus faut savoir que
Jean-Marie et Dieudonné avait préparé ce
spectacle déjà depuis des années c'est
un spectacle qui était prévu le titre
s'appelait foutu pour foutu et c'était
un visuel que Dieu donné avait fait donc
tout venait déjà de Dieudonné il y a 2
ans spectacle de Dieudonné c'était
Dieudonné Jean-Marie Bigard c'était
prévu il y a 2 ans d'accord ensuite il y
a eu le covid et Jean-Marie il faut
savoir que Jean-Marie est très gravement
malade Dieudonné aussi et en fait ils
ont voulu se rassembler tous les deux
parce qu'ils savent que c'est leur
dernier spectacle mais il a un diabète
très élevé il a une polyarthrite qui est
très élevée aussi et il a des problèmes
de cœur moi j'ai eu il y a quatre ans
des spectacles ont été annulés parce
qu'il nous avait fait des des AVC sur
scène et pour vous c'est une bonne idée
alors on en a discuté et c'est
Jean-Marie qui m'a dit Christelle je
suis foutue je ne remplis plus les
spectacles je ne fais plus de stage je
ne fais plus de Zénith je fais le point
virgule malheureusement je ne remplis
pas pour noter les spectateurs ils
devaient faire ce spectacle et il vous a
dit qu'il le ferait plus alors il ferait
plus moi il m'a dit écoute on va faire
croire que je ne fais plus ce spectacle
comme ça je peux faire les grosses têtes
comme ça je peux prendre mes cachets
tranquillement
bonjour Marie ben si Jean-Marie combien
effectivement alors c'est pas qu'à moi
parce que
c'est une affaire de plus de enfin moi
je parle pour entre les sociétés que je
représente ça peut monter jusqu'à 10
millions d'euros parce qu'il y en a oui
il n'y a pas que ma société en fait
Jean-Marie en fait avait un contrat de
production en fait qui qui est géré par
une société britannique et une société
française et il y a la société du
spectacle que j'ai parlé tout à l'heure
de la production américaine où on a
donné les droits pour que Jean-Marie et
Dieudo puisse faire cette fameuse
tournée avec Jésus production et ensuite
et ensuite il faut savoir qu'il y a la
production qui gère Dieudonné qui
attaquerait éventuellement Jean-Marie
Bigard pour lui réclamer effectivement
des dommages intérêts puisque Dieudo a
effectivement sa possession des éléments
qui montrent leurs échanges des des
textes des des messages Instagram est-ce
que ça vous dérangeait de travailler que
Dieudonné ou pas du tout mais pas du
tout j'ai travaillé avec moi avec judo
il y a 10 ans ça s'est très bien passé
sur Foxtrot moralement
parlant oui je vais répondre à la
demoiselle parce que je j'écoute les
personnes moralement parlant je me suis
toujours mis des œillères moi sur les
personnes je les juge pas moi je vois
que l'artiste qui a sur scène tout ce
qui se passe
comme vous Laurent
déjà en faisant de la radio et de la
télévision et je la vesti justement sur
des artistes que j'ai essayé de suivre
et que j'ai cette déforme quand je parle
d'eux sur les fleurs mais Laurent mais
moi c'est moi qui paye les Zéniths c'est
pas l'argent du gouvernement ou des
fonds de stratégie
moi c'est pareil tous mes spectacles je
les produits moi avec mon argent alors
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]